ANNOUNCER: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ROBERT FIELD: When
I was really young,
I used to go to a
television repair store
as often as possible to take
home one of the dead chassis.
And then I would take it apart.
And I don't know what
I was looking for,
but that was sort of
the empirical stuff.
I had no idea how a
television worked,
but I was really
curious about maybe
I could find it if
I just did stuff.
And what we've
been talking about
are ways in which we not
just generate numbers, like
parts of the television
chassis, but insight.
And there are we've talked
about three ways so far.
And one is Huckel theory,
where Huckel theory is just
a bunch of simple rules
and simple ideas for how
do you represent a large
family of related molecules.
And the Huckel theory
is incredibly simple,
but it enables you to
make really sophisticated
conclusions about
how things work
and what are the
important factors.
And so it's
basically a procedure
for distilling insight
from random observations.
Or maybe not random
observations,
but observations
of many properties
of many related molecules.
Then you've seen LCAOMO.
Based on the small variations
all treatment of H2 plus,
we got the idea of orbitals
and what makes a bond.
And then with the idea
that we can describe
the size of atomic
orbitals by the energy
below the ionization
limit, we can
make similar quantitative
predictions based
on this minimal basis set.
So we draw molecular
orbital diagrams.
And these molecular
orbital diagrams
are especially valuable for
isoelectronic and homologous
comparisons.
So isoelectronic would be,
let's say, nitrogen, CO, BF.
Molecules with the same
number of electrons.
And homologous would be
something like CO, SIO, GEO,
and so on.
And with the concept of
orbital size being related
to the ionization
energy of the atoms,
we can make a lot of
very useful comparisons.
And so we develop insight.
Now LCAOMO is a
variation of method,
and it can be a very
large variation of method.
And it could become of an issue.
But it's usually
not atomic orbitals.
It's just Gaussian
orbitals or something,
which is computationally
convenient.
And so it can be a procedure to
rationalize experience and make
predictions as you go from
the same number of electrons
but increasing
polarizability, polarity.
And these-- this is where
you develop chemical insight.
And it's really exciting.
And it's what was
missing when I would
take these chassis
from the repair shop
and chop them up into pieces.
And oh yeah, there's a magnet
in there and things like that.
It's much deeper.
And now perturbation theory
is a kind of a different thing
altogether.
Perturbation theory says
we do an experiment.
We measure something,
and we turn it
into something we really wanted.
The Rolling Stones
are telling us
that if you want to know how
a particular property depends
on internuclear distance,
and you can't directly
measure the property as a
function of internuclear
distance, well maybe
you can measure it
as a function of vibrational
and rotational quantum numbers.
And that's what
perturbation theory does.
It tells you how to get from
what you observe to what
you really want to know.
And it can be horrible in terms
of the algebraic exercises you
have to go through in order
to get what you really want
or from what you--
yes.
And today's lecture is going to
be an example of not the worst
thing you could ever do
with perturbation theory,
but pretty close to the worst.
OK, but all three of the
first things are related,
are associated with
getting insight
from either a crude calculation
refined against observations
or just the observations and
reducing those observations
to something really neat
about how things work.
Then the next two lectures will
be given by Professor Van Van
Voorhis and it's--
they will be on ab initio
theory, where basically you
don't assume anything.
You don't do anything except
solve for the exact energy
levels and wave functions.
Now this is not possible.
Directly you can do this by
making approximations, doing
an enormous variational
calculation.
Now many people think, well why
bother with approximate methods
when you can get the truth?
And the answer is the truth is
no more valuable than the parts
of a disabled television.
It's-- they're stuff.
But there's no insight there.
And quantum chemists who
do these calculations
are not just generating numbers.
They're trying to
explain how things work.
And it's the same business, it's
just the tools are different.
The goals are not just getting--
in spectroscopy we can measure
things to 10 or 11 digits.
And nobody cares.
I mean, how many digits?
It's a little bit challenging
to remember telephone numbers.
And having big tables of
10-digit numbers, so what?
But what do the
numbers tell you?
And this quest--
the same question
is asked by good
quantum chemists
by doing a series
of calculations
where they turn on
and off certain terms
in the Hamiltonian.
So it's the same thing.
I'm an experimentalist, but many
people who are experimentalists
think I'm a theorist
because I do weird stuff.
But I'm not a theorist.
Troy is a theorist.
And he does weird stuff too,
but he's not an experimentalist.
And we're both after insight.
And OK, so let's just--
I guess I'll just launch
it through the perturbation
theory.
OK.
But you do want to understand
the difference in how
these different methods, these
approximate methods, work,
and what they're good for, OK?
So the goal of
perturbation theory
is to go from
molecular constants
to structural constants,
or structural parameters.
Molecular constants are
like rotational constant,
vibrational constant, stuff that
you get by fitting the energy
levels you observe to a dumb
empirical expression, a power
series in quantum numbers.
Now there's lots of dumb
empirical expressions
you could use, and some
are better than others.
And perturbation theory
will often tell you
what is the right way to do it.
So you go from
molecular constants
to things in the potential.
So this is the displacement
from equilibrium,
and we would like
to know something
about how a molecule works.
And there also might be other
constants, like spin orbit,
and hyperfine, dipole moment.
And so let's just say
we have some observable,
and it is also a
function of coordinate.
And we'd like to know
what that function is.
But what we are able to do
is measure energy levels
as a function of
quantum numbers.
And so the information
that we really want,
the potential or
the internuclear
distance dependence of some
electronic property, that's
all gotten from
what we can observe
via perturbation theory.
It's a very powerful tool.
And it's not pretty,
but it always works.
And it's a good
basis for insight.
So perturbation
theory is a fit model.
The other methods, one doesn't
generally do a least-squares
fit to the--
of the adjustable
parameters in Huckel theory
to determine the
properties of a molecule.
One just says, OK,
I'm going to try these
because I think that attaching
an electro-negative atom
to a carbon atom is going to do
something that I can predict.
And maybe it's going to tell
me some surprises about how
its influence is not
just where it's attached,
but other places
in the molecule.
You know this from your
first organic courses.
You know all sorts
of tricks to be
able to predict reactivity
and things that are related.
But Huckel theory
is not a fit model.
LCAOMO theory is
not a fit model.
These are experience-based.
And you integrate
all sorts of stuff
that you learn from
comparing molecules.
And the comparing
of molecules is
what makes up for the deteriable
lists of the approximations.
And your job is to
hone your insight.
And so you have nothing to
protect you except the truth.
You can observe
molecules, but you
can't be guided to something
which is true, because there
is no calculation.
There's nothing exact and
there's nothing complete.
But in quantum chemistry you can
get really close to the truth.
But you don't know
anything about why.
And so you're doing
the same thing,
but from the opposite ends.
OK, but perturbation
theory is special
because you take a
huge amount of highly
accurate experimental data of
various types and you fit it.
And so I want to
talk about this.
So you have the Hamiltonian.
It's a matrix,
and it's expressed
in terms of parameters.
Let's just use
notation p, p of i.
A set of parameters.
So this is not a quantum
chemical, Hamiltonian.
It's a thing where we say there
are certain degrees of freedom,
and each one is controlled
by a number of parameters.
And we have the energy levels.
And so what you do
is you say let's
choose a set of
these parameters,
and calculate the energy
levels, and compare them
to the observed energy levels.
And it's not-- the first try,
it's not going to be good.
And then you say, OK, now I've
got to do a least-squares fit.
I have to vary the parameters
in this matrix Hamiltonian
to match the energy
levels and maybe
to match other things that you
can observe in the experiment.
But it's a complicated
least-squares fit,
because you have a matrix, and
you want to diagonalize it.
How are the parameters
related to the eigenvalues
and eigenvectors?
You don't know.
But when you're close, then you
can start fitting these things.
Then you can say, yeah, I know.
And then once you've done
that, you have not just
the energy levels, but you
have the wave functions.
Now again, you don't know
that there is something
missing in your Hamiltonian.
But you know that
from the data you
input you can match
all the energy levels.
But you didn't put
it in all the levels.
You put in just the
ones that you measured.
But you are arrogant.
And you think, well, maybe
I measured more than I--
I determined more
than I measured,
that I can extend the
measurements to other things.
And I told you at the beginning
of the course you cannot
observe the wave function.
But if you do this, if you do
a least-squares fit and match
the energy levels, you have a
pretty darn good representation
of the wave function.
And you can use that to
calculate other stuff,
especially dynamics.
Remember dynamics, at
least if the Hamiltonian is
independent of time,
the dynamics is going
to be a function of x and t.
But you start with the
initial preparation.
If you know that, then you,
because you know the energy
levels, you can calculate
the full x of t for all time.
So that's pretty powerful.
If you fitted enough stuff,
if your Hamiltonian has
the important things
in it, then you
are basically able to
do anything you want,
whether it's static or dynamic.
And if the Hamiltonian is time
dependent, you can do that too,
I just haven't
showed you how yet.
OK, so I really like
perturbation theory,
because it directly that deals
with whatever data you have.
And out from that,
you get this thing
which tells you everything,
unless there's something
that you didn't sample, that you
didn't know you didn't sample.
And then you discover that
your data and the predictions
are not in agreement.
And then that's when you--
you don't go home and
say, oh, I screwed up.
I got to go take a nap.
I don't-- you go home and
you say, let's celebrate,
because I discovered something
that was really missing.
And that's what we want to do.
OK, so I have to mess
around in the mud here.
Because the perturbation
theory you've
done so far has
been, perhaps, ugly,
but it's been kind of
simple because it's
basically vibration.
And now we've got
vibration and rotation.
And we have to combine
the two, and we
have to see whether there's
something special that we
can get from the combination.
And you bet there is.
OK, so we're going
to look at the energy
levels of a non-rigid,
non-harmonic, or anharmonic
oscillator.
And we're going to find
out how we generate
from an expression of
the potential energy
surface or potential
energy curve,
because what I'm going to be
talking about is diatomics.
But it all extends
to polyatomics.
And we're going to
calculate the relationships
between what you observed
and what you want to know.
So for a diatonic molecule,
we have a dumb representation
of the quantum numbers.
And we can write it.
And I'm just really
a stubborn person
about spectroscopic notation,
so I include this Hc convert
wave number unit, the reciprocal
centimeter units to energy.
But you'll never catch
me doing it in real life.
But that leads to all
sorts of algebraic errors
that I don't know I'm
making because I'm
so unused to doing this.
OK, so we have an expression for
the vibrational energy levels.
And I can't apolo--
I can't explain why
we use four letters
to represent one symbol, but
that's the traditional thing.
And for polyatomic
molecules, which
came after diatomic
molecules, we
start using only two letters.
Instead of omega
XE, we just use XE.
But since I'm a diatomician, I'm
going to do this sort of thing.
And that's v plus 1/2 squared.
And then the next term is
omega YE v plus a 1/2 cubed.
OK, and so then that's
the vibrational part.
And then we have
the rotational part.
The equilibrium internuclear
distant rotational constant
minus alpha e times v plus 1/2.
Times JJ plus 1.
And then minus DE, the
centrifugal distortion
constant, times JJ plus
1 quantity squared.
And we can have
more constants here.
We can have additional
constants there.
But basically we
have constants, which
are known by multiplying
a particular combination
of vibrational and rotational
constants, quantum numbers.
And so these are the
things we can determine,
or sometimes we
determine some of these
and we want to get a
prediction of the others
because they're outside
of our observation.
And the potential is going to
be dependent on the displacement
from equilibrium and
the rotational constant.
And so there will be
terms in the potential,
like 1/2 KQ squared plus
1/6 AQ cubed, et cetera.
So we have another
dumb power series.
And fortunately, we
know that as we go up
in the displace-- in this
displacement coordinate,
the coefficients get
to be really small.
And so we don't need to have
a lot of these parameters.
But we should have at least two,
the harmonic and the cubic one.
And we know for molecules
the cubic parameter gives you
a potential curve,
which resembles reality.
It's hard wall here,
soft wall there.
Molecules break.
Now this has the unfortunate
property of doing that.
And so it's got
death built into it.
But it doesn't really
matter, because you basically
are looking at increasingly
wide regions of the potential.
And the fact that it
does something terrible
in your simple representation
is almost irrelevant.
But you have to
be aware that you
can tunnel through barriers.
And when you start being able
to tunnel through barriers,
and it depends on how close you
are to the top of the barrier
and how wide it is, then
you start seeing effects.
And then this term is
going to give nonsense.
But there is a
domain of goodness
where you don't have
to worry about that.
So we have this,
and then we have
the rotational constant
kind of contributing
to the effect of potential,
which is HCV of R JJ plus 1.
Now here I've got--
here I have coordinates.
Here I have quantum numbers.
How can I do that?
It's because central force
problems can be represented
in a universal form.
And so we can just integrate
over the angular part
of the problem.
And so now we have a
mixed representation.
But this guy is still a function
of R or Q. And so this v of R
is an operator.
It's not just a constant.
Some people call it the
rotational constant operator.
Kind of stupid.
And so our job is
now to figure out
how to get from this
parameter rise potential
to the energy levels.
Of course, we start
with the energy levels.
And we're going to want to
determine the parameters
in the potential.
But you've got to
have that connection.
So this rotational operator has
some constants in front of it.
And this is in wave
number of units,
because I'm a spectroscopist.
And we have the vibrational
frequency, 1 over 2 pi C. K
over mu square root.
Also in wave number of units.
Now the first problem
is we don't like R,
because harmonic
oscillators are expressed
in terms of displacement
from equilibrium.
And so we know that Q
is equal to R minus RE,
or R is equal to Q plus RE.
So we want to replace
this operator R by this,
an operator plus a constant.
So 1 over R squared
can be expressed as 1
over RE squared, the equivalent
internucleus, plus 1 over Q
over RE.
Plus [INAUDIBLE] squared.
So this is the power
series expansion,
but we only keep the
first term generally.
And so now we're
ready to go to work.
And we can say we have
B as a function of Q
is equal to B of E, the
equilibrium value 1 minus 2Q
or RE plus 3Q squared
over RE squared.
And there's more terms,
but this is enough.
You bet it's enough.
By the time this
lecture is over,
you're going to want not
ever to see this stuff again.
OK, so we have now
a representation
of the rotational
operator in terms
of a constant term, a linear
term, and a squared term in Q.
And we know how to do matrix
elements of Qs, right?
So we know we're in business.
And we have the potential as
another power series in Qs.
So everything is going
to come together.
It's just going to be will the
migraine wipe out your ability
to pay any attention to
this after we're done.
OK, so I don't want
to cover that up yet.
So we know that this
displacement operator
can be replaced by the creation
and annihilation operators.
And so we have 4 pi C,
mu omega E square root.
A plus A dagger are friends.
These guys, we hardly
need to take a deep breath
to know what to do with those.
And so we're going to want
to express all of the--
all of the actors here,
these guys and those guys,
in terms of expressions in
the creation and annihilation
operators.
So for the rotational
constant expansion,
we're going to need
something like 2Q over RE.
And that, after a
little bit of algebra,
is 4BE over omega E square
root times A plus A dagger.
And we need 3Q squared
over RE squared.
And that's going to be 3BE
over omega E, A plus A dagger
squared.
So all of the terms
can be expressed,
can be reduced to constants
that we care about,
or that are easily measured,
and these powers of As
and a daggers.
Now this is-- you have
notes, printed notes.
And I'm following
them pretty well,
although there are a few
typos, which I hope to correct.
And so we do a similar
thing for the terms here.
And we're only going to keep--
we're only going
to look at this.
We're not going to go to Q 1/4.
But this is bad enough.
OK, and this is part of
the zero order Hamiltonian.
So we're going to
have another term,
and that's going to be
1/6 little a Q cubed.
OK, so that's-- little a is
the anharmonicity parameter.
And what is its sign?
Can we know its sign
from experiment?
You said yes.
Why do you say yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ROBERT FIELD: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: It's
cubed, so it's odd.
So there's [INAUDIBLE].
ROBERT FIELD: The
only way you know
the sign of an off diagonal
matrix element is--
I'm sorry, is if there is a
diagonal element of it that
can be put into the E, the first
order correction to the energy.
As soon as you have
to square it when
you do second order perturbation
theory, you've lost the sign.
But here we know the sign
because of physical insight.
We know that this kind of a
potential would be nonsense.
So we know that A has a
sign and it's negative.
OK, so we have a over 6
times our favorite parameter
here to the 3/2 power times
A plus A dagger cubed.
Now this is something--
you do the operator
algebra before you launch
into a horrible calculation.
And so we know how to
do this in principle
to reduce this to a
simple expression.
And now we take this
part, this thing,
and we're just going to call it
capital A. Because we want it--
we don't want to
clutter up what is going
to be a terrible thing anyway.
And we can always convert back
to the little a at the end
if we need to.
OK, so now I've set the stage.
I'll leave this for a while.
That really is-- as you know,
I really love revision theory,
because it's the tool
that I use all the time.
And it's a
psychological condition
that is not curable, all right?
So what do we want?
We want E0 as a
function of E and J.
And that's just the J H0 VJ.
And we know that HC will make
EB plus 1/2 plus HCBEJJ plus 1.
OK, well this goes in
the energy denominators.
And so that's good,
because we need
energy denominators as well
as the zero order energies.
Right now we need to know the
bad stuff, the thing that's
outside of the zero
order Hamiltonian,
which is everything.
And so we have this is HC
times BE JJ plus 1 times--
I'm sorry, I have to erase this.
Minus BE over 4BE
over a big E square
root times A plus
A dagger plus 3 BE.
3BE over omega E times A plus
A dagger quality squared.
So that's the rotational part.
And then we have the
vibrational power,
which we have A, A
plus A dagger cubed.
OK, so now we look at
this thing and we say,
oh well, this has matrix
elements delta V equals
plus or minus 1.
And this has delta V equals
plus or minus 2 and 0.
And this has delta V equals plus
and minus 3 plus and minus 1.
We always want to sort things
according to the selection
rules, because we always
combine the things
with the same selection rules.
And it's best to do
that at the beginning
rather than somehow trying
to do it at the end.
Because if you have the
same selection rule,
you have cross terms.
And that's really important.
The cross terms are where a
lot of good stuff happens.
OK, so we know E0.
And we would know E1 if
there are any off the--
there are any diagonal matrix
elements of this operator.
This should be a plus as well.
So this is H1.
And this doesn't have
any diagonal elements.
But this one does.
And it's actually
something you encountered,
I think, on exam two.
I'm not sure, but you've
certainly encountered
the diagonal element of this.
And so if we look at A
plus A dagger squared,
we get A squared
plus A dagger squared
plus 2 number operator plus 1.
And that's diagonal.
So we have a diagonal
element, and that gives us E1.
So E1 of E and J is HC6BE
squared over omega E times J, J
plus 1, B plus 1/2.
OK, well that looks
pretty good, because this
is the coefficient of--
we have an expression
for the energy levels,
which includes the
E minus alpha E, B
plus 1/2 of times JJ plus 1.
So we have a term that involves
B plus 1/2 and JJ plus 1.
And it has a name.
Alpha minus alpha.
And here we have a
term which has those,
that quantum number dependents.
And it has a value.
And so it's telling
us that alpha E,
and I'll put on this
harmonic oscillator,
is equal to minus HC6BE
v squared over omega
E. One constant.
Now it's also telling you
that B of E increases with V.
And for a harmonic
oscillator, you
have an equal lobe at each
turning point, the largest
lobe.
But they're equal in magnitude.
So one can ask, at
the inner turning
point is the change in
the rotational operator,
or is it larger--
is this change in BE larger
relative to the equilibrium
value, or is this larger?
And the answer is we're
talking about 1 over R squared.
And 1 over R squared gets really
large at small r as opposed
to getting smaller at large
R. And the amount of change
is much greater at small r.
And so that causes the
effective rotational
constant to increase.
But we know for a harmonica--
for an anharmonic oscillator,
we have a small lobe
here and a big lobe here.
And so we expect
that there's going
to be a battle between the
harmonic contribution to alpha
and the anharmonic contribution.
And we expect that
this is going to win.
Why?
Because every time
anybody measures alpha,
it's a positive number.
And that's why it was expressed
in the formula, which I've
concealed, with a negative sign,
to take into account that alpha
is always--
the contribution
is always negative,
and so alpha is always positive.
Yeah, and these things are--
it's historical.
But anyway, so we
have a contribution
which has the wrong sign.
And we know we're going to
get another contribution
from the interaction between
the rotation and the vibration,
and that this is going
to make things right OK.
And it comes from a term.
OK.
All right, there's no way
I can make this simpler.
Just have to bear
with me and I will--
so we have delta V equals
plus and minus 1 matrix
elements from both the A
plus A dagger and the A
plus A dagger cubed terms.
And we have-- we have this in
both the anharmonic expression
and in the rotational
constant operator.
We know what these--
how these things work out.
And so delta V equals plus
and minus 1 terms from the A
plus A dagger cubed V
plus 1 and V, V minus 1.
So we can work these things out.
And this one is 3V
plus 1/2 to the 3/2.
And this is 3V
plus V to the 3/2.
So all of this stuff,
you want to simplify it
as you go but it.
And these come from
the A term, the A,
A plus A dagger cubed' term.
We don't have a term that's
linear at A plus A dagger
from the anharmonicity,
but we do--
and we do have a
squared term, but that's
the harmonic correction.
So we start here, with
A plus A dagger cubed.
And then we're going
to want to look
at the delta V equals plus
or minus 2, and delta V
equals plus and minus 3 terms.
And there's lots of algebra.
You can do all these things.
There's nothing
challenging here.
It's just how do you keep
this stuff that you derived
that you're going
to need in a place
that you can find it again,
because the pages just
get filled with garbage.
OK.
So the best way for me to do
this is to write the results
in the next-to-the-final step,
and then in the final step,
and show what goes to what.
So the second order correction
is a function of EJ.
We're going to have terms that
involve the delta V equals
plus or minus 1.
And we're going to get that
from the cubic correction
through the harmonic oscillator
and the linear correction
to the rotational concept.
So we're going to get
an expression that
looks like this.
B squared minus
2AB plus A squared.
So this is a B term.
This is the anharmonic term.
We have a cross term.
There are going to be three
terms in this expression.
OK, and so let's do that.
How much time I have?
Not very much time.
Well that's good,
because you won't have
to watch much more of this.
OK, so we have the
HcBe JJ plus 1.
And this guy is
squared, because we're
doing second-order
perturbation theory.
This is just the B term squared.
And then we have
4BE be over omega E.
And then we have the delta V of
1 and minus 1 matrix elements.
V plus 1 over minus HC omega,
and V plus V over HC omega.
We have the energy denominators,
two energy denominators
of opposite side and
similar identical magnitude.
And we always do that because
then the algebra is simple.
If we do-- we fail to do
that, you might as well just
go to a booby hatch right
away, because there's just
no way you're going to
retain your sanity if you
don't combine the terms of delta
V plus 1 and delta V minus 1.
OK, and this is the first term.
And there is the next term in
this sum, which is the AB term.
And so we have a minus
2 times HCV JJ plus 1.
And it's not squared, because
it's one B and one A term.
And so we get 4BE over
omega E square root.
And then the A part.
And we get 3B plus
1/2 to the 3/2 times
V plus 1/2 to the 1/2,
or minus HC omega E.
And then the other term, which
is 3V to the 3/2, V to 1/2,
over HC omega E.
We have to combine
these two terms.
And the combination is easy.
And then there is--
so this term number two.
And number three is the
squared anharmonic term.
So I'm going to skip it,
since I'm basically done.
There's just a lot
of garbage like this.
And at the end, we have an
expression, term by term,
which simplifies.
And we get the second-order
correction to the energy, VJ,
is equal to minus HcBe
cubed over HC omega.
No, not HC.
Just over omega E squared
times JJ plus 1 squared.
Well this is nice, because we
have a term that just involves
J, and it's negative, that
says as a molecule rotates,
the molecule stretches, the
rotational constant decreases.
This is called
centrifugal distortion.
And this is a very
famous expression
that DE is equal to 4BE
cubed over omega squared.
I left out a 4.
So this is the
Kratzer relationship.
And that turns out to be
of the most valuable ones,
because the
centrifugal distortion
constant is extremely
sensitive to contagion.
If there is a perturbation,
if there is something missing,
this centrifugal
distortion constant
will have a crazy value.
And if it doesn't ever--
if there's nothing wrong,
then it will say,
well, OK, I can--
if I know something
about B and omega,
I can determine how the
rotational energy levels get
closer together
as you go up in V.
And if you have only a
pure rotation spectrum,
then you actually--
where you're not
sampling anything
having to do with
vibration, you actually
can determine the
vibrational constant
from the centrifugal distortion.
And I should tell you
that spectroscopists come
in families, or they used to.
Pure rotation, infrared
vibration rotation,
electronic vibration
rotation, electronic.
And so the microwavers, who
really have only rotation
to look at, are
kind of deprived.
And they just
don't know anything
about electronic
degrees of freedom.
But they know how to get
the vibrational frequency
from the rotational spectrum,
which is kind of nice.
Gives them something to do.
And there's more terms.
And we're really done,
but it's all in the notes.
And so what we get is for the
constant OAEXE, and center
of distortion, and
alpha E and beta, which
is the vibrational distortion
of the centrifugal distortion
constant, we get all these
in terms of omega and B.
So it's a nice closed
set where you get the--
you're able to predict how
certain constants depend
on the most fundamental
ones, omega E and BE.
That's kind of neat.
And it's both a way of
extending your observations
and telling well, there's
something missing,
because these constants
aren't coming out right.
It's also a subject of
great consternation.
Because if you're a quantum
chemist, what you do
is you determine a lot of stuff
by derivatives at equilibrium.
The derivatives, the
potential at equilibrium,
are basically telling you
the shape of the potential
at moderately low energy.
And it also turns out to be
something with modern quantum
chemistry.
You can get all these
derivatives pretty accurately.
The trouble is measuring
derivatives here
and using the energy
formulas gives you
slightly different
values from what you
get from perturbation theory.
So what we have
is two communities
who are very sophisticated
using the same names
for different quantities.
It's dangerous.
And it's also not understood
by the two communities.
And so people are
struggling and struggling
to get agreement between
experiment and theory.
And it's apples and oranges,
but it's a subtle thing.
OK, so that's basically
all I want to say
about perturbation theory.
I will have one more lecture
dealing with perturbation
theory, and that lecture
is on Van der Waals
interactions between molecules
and why we get liquids.
OK.